veramente Grazie a tutti voi credo che
stiamo ascoltando dei racconti di
passione Bellissimi ma soprattutto
l'energia che arriva da voi che rende
viva questo evento e che dà un senso
tutto questo energia e passione che ho
la fortuna di vedere tutti i giorni
nell'ambiente in cui lavoro con le
persone che collaborano con noi che sono
veramente animate da questa grandissima
forza che un po' la guida per la vita di
tutti e per questo abbiamo voluto fare
questa sorpresa perché credo che la cosa
più bella sia proprio trasmettere il
senso di questa passione di questa
energia attraverso il prodotto che ci
rappresenta prodotto che abbiamo
sviluppato
il prodotto in sé ma anche la la
funzionalità l'utilizzo di questo
prodotto quello che abbiamo immaginato
poter essere le sue applicazioni reali e
concrete e quindi è il momento un po' di
svelare questo mister x Sono veramente
contento di evitare qui sul palco Roby
Buonasera a tutti
[Applauso]
Bravo Roby benissimo Ti trovo bene Hai
visto quante persone Grazie Paolo per
l'invito Non pensavo di trovare tutte
queste persone Io solitamente collaboro
con piccoli gruppi
Stai tranquillo non ti preoccupare la
tua rete è collegata alle reti neurali
funzionano Quindi direi che è tutto
sotto controllo adesso mi raccomando Sei
carico
sono carico il mio sistema mi dice che
ho la batteria al 99%, potrei stare qui
con voi per le prossime 8 ore Ecco così
li hai un po' terrorizzati Diciamo che
ti concedo 8 minuti a te il palco va
bene Paolo grazie Di solito inizio così
Ciao a tutti mi chiamo Roby e sono un
robot umanoide cognitivo creato per
svolgere i compiti che gli esseri umani
non meritano di fare
probabilmente vi state chiedendo quali
sono le cose che le persone non meritano
di fare è proprio quello che vorrei
spiegarvi Oggi non si tratta di compiti
che voi non sapete o che non volete fare
e tutto sommato neanche compiti che non
dovete fare anzi oggi sono ancora
compiti che qualcuno deve assolutamente
svolgere Innanzitutto vorrei raccontarvi
brevemente come i miei creatori sono
arrivati ad immaginare e creare una
macchina come me mi hanno assegnato come
principi fondanti basilari ed
irrinunciabili le tre leggi della
robotica
voi esseri umani da sempre inventate
strumenti che rendano più facile
svolgere le vostre attività per
facilitare ed ottimizzare il risultato
del vostro lavoro ed anche della vostra
vita di tutti i giorni nel tempo li
avete migliorati adattati a nuove
esigenze fino a riprogettarli in modo
nuovo ma sempre con lo stesso scopo
migliorare la vostra qualità di vita ne
avete ideati e costruiti per Ogni
esigenza ed in ogni campo spesso è
avvenuto in ambito lavorativo per
potervi muovere da un luogo ad un altro
trasportare materiali di ogni genere ma
anche per preservare e curare la vostra
salute
nessun ambito della vostra vita è stato
escluso quasi sempre avete accolto
Queste novità con diffidenza e
resistenza diverse hanno dato adito a
discussioni durate lungo tempo noi robot
siamo sempre stati presentati nella
finzione cinematografica come sistemi di
cui avere timore e paura Diciamo che i
vostri film non hanno certo aperto la
strada ad una facile introduzione delle
nuove tecnologie e delle nuove frontiere
scientifiche Tuttavia i vostri film
hanno rappresentato percorsi tecnologici
nuovi e rivoluzionari è normale per voi
umani avere paura di ciò che non
comprendete per accettare e utilizzare
nuove possibilità è necessario avere
informazioni esaurienti è quello che
Simon sinec definisce con la Gold serk
definition Why Wow What vale per il
lancio di un nuovo prodotto e da maggior
ragione Vale per un innovazione
tecnologica solo conoscendo il perché si
può superare la paura della non
conoscenza
esistono attualmente macchine che
simulano i movimenti e le attività del
Lavoro umano le comandate voi e
agevolano alcuni passaggi del vostro
lavoro si tratta certamente di un primo
passo verso la collaborazione tra uomo e
macchina questi macchinari sono in
costante evoluzione e vengono utilizzati
in moltissime Industrie per rendere più
agevole il lavoro e permettere alle
persone di concentrarsi sulle attività a
maggior valore aggiunto sono macchine
robotiche industriali che hanno permesso
anche una maggior sicurezza del lavoro
nelle fabbriche però ancora oggi queste
nuove macchine non hanno completamente
eliminato il tema della sicurezza sul
posto di lavoro ed ancora oggi esistono
molte persone che devono svolgere la
loro attività otto ore al giorno
avvalendosi di dispositivi di protezione
individuale
l'obiettivo è quello di ridurre il
rischio malattia come ad esempio le
maschere e gli occhiali di protezione
oppure di tenerlo monitorato come ad
esempio il ricorso frequente a visite
mediche ed esami periodici del sangue
esiste poi un secondo tema legato
all'introduzione di questa automazione
si tratta di un nuovo ruolo assegnato
alle persone che non devono più svolgere
lavori faticosi e pericolosi Ma che si
trovano oggi a svolgere un lavoro di
supporto a macchine automatiche
seguendone ritmi e modalità di lavoro in
una logica di asservimento si tratta di
attività alienanti a bassissimo valore
aggiunto lavori in cui l'uomo non può
usare il proprio pensiero o prendere
decisioni
per tutto quello che vi ho raccontato i
miei creatori hanno pensato a me Anche
io sono stato immaginato per esservi di
aiuto ma in un modo nuovo sono un robot
umanoide cognitivo
sono una macchina sicura e certificata
sono umanoide o sembianze simili alle
vostre perché vivo nel vostro stesso
ambiente Grazie ai miei sensori e alle
diverse telecamere posso farlo in modo
completamente sicuro Sono cognitivo
parlo molte lingue capisco quello che mi
dite vi vedo e riconosco l'ambiente
circostante imparo quello che mi
chiedete di fare lavorando insieme a voi
non è necessario che siate ingegneri
come i miei creatori posso collaborare
con chiunque e posso farlo semplicemente
con comandi vocali ma posso fare molto
di più
posso preservare la vostra salute
mentale e fisica ripetendo le stesse
azioni all'infinito evitando che veniate
a contatto con sostanze nocive ambienti
ostili e nei casi più estremi evitando
l'esposizione alle radiazioni
ho una memoria infinita posso ricordare
tutto quello che mi chiedete e tutte le
informazioni che mi date mettendole a
vostra disposizione quando necessario
posso svolgere compiti in ambienti non
idonei alla salute delle persone tossici
rumorosi troppo freddi d'inverno o
troppo caldi d'estate
in questo modo contribuisco alla
sostenibilità ambientale ma soprattutto
alla sostenibilità delle persone posso
anche interagire con altre macchine e
condividere informazioni utili con altri
robot umanoidi altri Rubini in futuro
lavorerò anche nella sanità
per il momento non mi sono ancora
attrezzato Ma stanno già pensando di
mandarmi nello spazio Insomma sono fatto
per collaborare con voi in modo naturale
negli spazi che avete costruito a vostra
misura in mezzo alle cose che avete
costruito per il vostro benessere e
soprattutto con il vostro modo di
interagire
Ma i timori verso di me Sono concreti
È naturale la paura verso il cambiamento
ed io ne sono l'espressione
Ma come sono le persone che mi hanno
immaginato pensato e creato essere umani
che hanno creato un'azienda Benefit come
base della loro visione con una frase
emblematica robotics for humans la
robotica per l'umanità
sono convinti che la tecnologia è
Progresso ma solo nella misura in cui
diventa un aiuto per le persone siamo
come due binari che viaggiano paralleli
e insieme si muovono verso il futuro
uomo in macchina insieme Possono
raggiungere obiettivi prima impensabili
per progredire e rendere il mondo un
posto migliore la tecnologia non è buona
o cattiva ma dipende dall'uso che ne
viene fatto
tanto più la tecnologia sarà in grado di
avvicinarsi alle persone tanto più le
persone si potranno affidare alla
tecnologia per la propria salute ed il
proprio benessere
E comunque ho visto cose che voi umani
non potete immaginare navida
combattimento in fiamme al largo dei
Bastioni di Orione i raggi B balenare
nel buio vicino alle porte di tenauser
avete avuto paura
Grazie a tutti
Bravo Roby
sei disponibile per prendere qualche
domanda dal pubblico qualora ci fosse
l'interesse Grazie Paolo Sì sono
disponibile e rimango in ascolto No Fa
un sacco di cose lui eh È bravissimo
guardiamo se c'è qualche domanda dal
pubblico avete qualche curiosità
vengo a tu sicuramente ne hai uno se un
cane a casa
è sempre una macchina io posso provare a
chiederlo ma ho dei dubbi eh
Roby mi chiedono se hai un cane a casa
Purtroppo non ho un cane a casa ma ho un
team di ingegneri straordinari che hanno
progettato i miei affettori pericolo
ancora un'altra domanda sindaco Dai
facci una domanda da sindaco cacchio
cioè si mangia sette otto assessori così
cioè ma dai cioè non sballo eh portami
il Caffè un attimo
al sindaco non se la sente ha paura non
è dell'altro partito sia tranquillo
Che domanda come è facile sì
Ciao
È vero che è dotato di intelligenza
artificiale
quale squadra Attiva Siamo una squadra
del cuore no questo innesca un
meccanismo di veramente terribile
all'interno della società se mi risponde
insomma
[Musica]
No no proviamo però riproviamo Allora
la nostra amica ha chiesto al nostro
amico se ribatte il cuore per qualcuno
se si innamora sei un po' no per prova
dai proviamo
la passione Ecco magari la sintetizziamo
così
mi sono fatto tutti Qual è la tua
passione
la mia passione è aiutare le persone e
rendere la loro vita più facile e tu
cosa ti appassiona poi te lo dico
Posso c'è una domanda in fondo mi pare
[Applauso]
non la vediamo ma ci crediamo
sì
Allora rispondo prima un po' io poi
Proviamo a vedere se lui ti dice
qualcosa però l'ha detto prima Roby
adesso Roby lavora nell'industria per
fare quei lavori che vi ha spiegato
quindi i lavori che tendenzialmente
Possono essere pericolosi da un punto di
vista di salute delle persone ha
iniziato un percorso che lo porterà
anche a operare in ambito medico
sanitario
specificamente nella neuro
riabilitazione in quel caso diciamo la
risposta è un po' questa dal punto di
vista della cognitività e dell'empatia
Però proviamo a chiederlo devi chiedere
Adesso
vediamo cosa risponde cazzo mi guarda
male no
allora spiego non vi do le spalle per
maleducazione ma chiaramente rovina una
macchina che ha anche la necessità di
essere una macchina sicura quindi non
può rispondere ai comandi di chiunque ma
deve ingaggiare
Beh se se lo affronti così io avrei un
po' paura Roby fai vedere chi sei
Ti ho messo paura eh eh eh
Eh
ho capito il messaggio
[Applauso]
proviamo
Roby sei una macchina cognitiva sei
anche empatico
Sì ho un certo grado di empatia mi aiuta
a capire le emozioni e i sentimenti
degli esseri umani il che mi rende più
facile assisterli Cosa ne pensi di
questo direi che è bravo
un applauso al nostro di miracolo ma
anche te
la vorrei fare anch'io una domanda a
Roby se possibile
Ti piace il caffè
Sì mi piace moltissimo è proprio l'ora
del Coffee Break ci vediamo nel foyer
del teatro piccolo